I had a relative recommend protocell. So protocell is something that I think is a great protocol.
But we'll talk about the caveats of that. So I write a lot about protocell. As a matter of fact,
you could look up information on protocell in my book or you could look up information to protocell on
our blog. All right, I bought protocell 50 but later read somewhere where protocell 30 is the type.
So there's a protocell 30. So there's a protocell 50 and there's a protocell 23.
Was the type recommended to help with prostate cancer? So I would disagree with that.
protocell 50 is really the type to use for prostate cancer. protocell 23 is the type you use for any
other cancer. So you did buy the right one. So that was good. Half a bottle of 50 left,
we've been official managers. You have prostate cancer. Yes. So the instructions say things like
co-cutated vitamin C reduce the effectiveness of protocell, which is correct. So protocell is an oxidizing
agent. So when you're taking protocell, so protocell 50, for instance, you have to take protocell on a
very tight schedule. It says it right on the bottle. It goes protocell 50. It's every five hours or every
four and a half hours. You have to take your other supplements at hour 2.5 right in between doses.
So let's say you're taking it at eight o'clock and then at 12.30, you have to take your protocell at 10.30.
Or you have to take your other supplements at 10.30. The makers of protocell and I actually interview one
of the inventors of protocell, but I lost the interview. So I never got it. This was back when I first
did my wrote my book in 2010. And it was actually before that. And you know, he was, you know,
he recommends that if you can. So if you're new to the cancer, and you're going to do try protocell
as a therapy, you don't take any anti-oxidants. So co-cutated vitamin C, alpha-lopeic acid,
glutathione, glutathione precursors, all those things are anti-oxidants that you would have to take
either. You'd either go off of those for a period of time while you're doing a protocell protocol
or you have to take them mid between doses of protocell. That's the key. You just can't, if you take
your anti-oxidants, at the same time you take your protocell, basically you're negating the benefits
of the protocell. You're really not going to give yourself a fair shake on whether protocell's going to work.
You certainly can, you know, just, you know, pulse your anti-oxidants, and you certainly could pulse
your protocell. Maybe you take your anti-oxidants on the weekend and you'd only do the protocell
five days a week during the week. You could do things like that, get creative. So, you know, we're trying
to get you to to pray about your protocol, what you're going to do, and so that you are taking
responsibility for your health and developing that relationship with God that you need to have
so that you could hear His still small voice in your heart leading you. I can't hear that. I
don't know what to do. I need somebody to tell me what to do. I don't know what to do. I get it. But
this is what maturity is all about. We need to all mature to that level to be able to hear Him.
Jesus said, by sheep here, by voice, and I know them. So, we need to just be still and know that He is
God and ask Him to lead us in the ways that we're supposed to go and the things that we're supposed
to do.